Derek good morning how are you I'm doing
great thank you for having me
how's the leg oh here old man I did once
we started up the offseason program back
I think I guess it was April I was able
to do everything so I was really blessed
man and you know fortunate but it wasn't
worse you knew you broke it right away
how yeah I was sitting out to the side
oh it was he was sticking out and I
tried to move it back in and there it
wouldn't move you know I could feel it
catching so you know I knew that I knew
it wasn't good but I think to the you
know I've torn ligaments in my ankles
you know playing basketball when I was
younger a phenom rolled my ankle plenty
of times and I knew it this was
completely different feeling so I knew I
knew it was broke but I was still
holding out hope that maybe they can
tape it up I can get back out there but
that wasn't the case how many surgeries
have you had oh in my in my life or
let's go let me thank I had one when I
was little
on my right feminine my dad says that
that was the reason that I can throw it
out she always likes to let me know that
but you know I think that the one in
college that one I think I've had three
three or four four I think I've had four
yeah but when you're on the outside
looking in watching your team it you
know that helpless feeling but what was
that like when you know you've got a
playoff team you've helped lead them to
what 12 wins and you have to sit there
and watch them yeah it sucked you know
it is so hard to win in this league you
know a lot of our games we won in the
fourth quarter and things like that so
you know we definitely earned 12 wins
and you know when we sit back and you
know you know we're getting ready for
the playoffs you know we knew that we
had worked really hard to get to where
we're at and just in a moment man it all
changed and you know you want to know
why a lot less you know we try and do
things the right way you know we try and
be good people in these things but
it was an amazing time you know just
just to really be you know who I say I
am and just love on people and just
continue to be myself and show them that
I know wasn't our time this year we're
going to come back out of next year if
you go to a cookout could people expect
you to throw the football around
yes actually it actually happened other
than my wife's family and we're sitting
there and I'm just talking you know
summer when some of her family and
cousins and we're having a good time and
all sudden I see a football get broke
out and like all eyes like go to me I
was like okay all right I guess I just
forgot to do with this but would you
rather not be the quarterback you know I
don't want to be you know at those
things but then it gets to a point when
I see other people throwing that I just
say you know I think I got it right does
anybody ever say throw it as hard as you
can you know what I've had that happen a
lot of times in my life actually which
is hilarious because you know they'll
see me throw one on TV and I'd like to
they say you got two strong charms you
know and like well you know I try you
know and I thought as hard as you can't
and actually a great story I was at my
buddy's house when I was in seventh
grade okay
and back then I could really I could
already throw the ball about 65 70 yards
and he said this college tied in was at
his house Dean Bercy Houston and he said
come on man I put a college quarterback
store as far as you can I threw it at
him snapped his finger to the side so
quick he was screaming and running down
the street and so I usually tell people
that story after they say don't as far
as you can and so they're like oh yeah
maybe not as hard as you can so yeah
he's Derek Carr the Raiders quarterback
now that everybody knows how much you
make I just have to see it though it's
got to be weird that everybody looks
like people look at you differently I'm
going to guess because you're now the
highest-paid quarterback in the game
yeah you know it's kind of weird you
know I love like helping people and I
love doing special things especially for
the moment just for ran
strangers too you know but now it's like
if they know who you are and you walk
into a restaurant they're like ah man
look at you can I buy my meal not if you
ask you know you know are you different
to similar game are you different tipper
now no I've always been very generous my
wife worked in the restaurant business
and she was a waitress so I know how
that goes so I'm always see if she's
taught me well I've always been very
generous I want other people that you
know take care of us but yeah it's so
weird that people like know your salary
and actually it's not but I think it's
more than actually what it is because
they forget about taxes and all those
things but they say like and you can
like get an island and stuff like no no
I think you just get random people
saying these going students like you
have no clue man but then we were very
fortunate and blessed but yeah it is it
is a different thing when you walk
around and people like know exactly they
can look it up I was like well I want to
know exactly what you make ya know you
know but you back back loaded because of
state income tax in Las Vegas
is that your the strategy by your agent
yeah I mean in a very small sense of it
yes you know I didn't really care about
you know getting all the cash in my
hands right now you know I trust you
know rezi and what he told me and you
know and the fact that they love me and
they want me here forever so I said well
if that's the case man you know
obviously anything can happen but you
know bank banking myself continuing to
work hard and you know be a good player
for you I said let's try and push some
of that back obviously you know for tax
reasons and those things but also more
importantly the number one reason why I
wanted to do that is because we have
guys coming up that we needed to get
signed and I wanted to help the team do
that so you know getting guys like Gabe
Jackson getting guys like Khalil you
know Mari is going to come up at some
point I wanted to make sure we could
keep our team together and that's the
number one reason we did it is I did not
want to hurt my team and you know have
some of my best friends you don't leave
and go play somewhere else do you feel
like you're the best quarterback you're
the highest-paid
but and I know that's temporary but but
where do you sort of feel like you stand
with your competitors oh man you know
when it comes to accolades I'm nowhere
near what they've done yes you know
there's a lot of rings out there there's
a lot I been telling Y Macallan twice I
was yeah I would love to you know throw
against any of those guys you know and I
have played against a lot of them you
know and you know stood toe-to-toe with
them and don't to guess them and you
know there's never going to be a time
where immune FL like you play against
some of the best guys in league like I
can't make that throw yeah they can
everyone can make so you know it's not
like well I can make this throw better
than mammoth no no everyone can make
every throw but tell me why I will
always I'm super competitive now you
know you know I will never say nah man a
guy can throw better than they had never
I'll never be one of those but I will
never ever take anything away from
anybody also are you Golden State
Warriors Finn
you know I pull for them I've been a
Laker fan since I was little so I am a
Laker fan but I do pull for the hometown
team especially there's a lot of good
guys on that paint to root for hmm but
if the Lakers are playing the Golden
State Warriors who you rooting for all
my liquor Jersey okay we got it
so stead of Steph for a panther jersey
for the Carolina game when they came and
played us all right I would definitely
wear my Laker jersey if they're playing
I mean I did yell when Kobe played his
last game at Oracle during his last
season we actually wins that right by
the linkers bench you know got the
median afterwards and talk to him so
yeah I was definitely all about the
Lakers that day i we have over/under the
amount of monies spent after you signed
this contract
did you treat yourself okay so we first
started at a million dollars and I went
now that's way too high I'm going to say
did you spend $10,000 or more on
something oh oh yes yeah I did oh well I
did kinda had to buy the pair I had to
pay my brother back for something done a
long time ago wait you owe David money
so what we did is is when we started our
gym there's a small thing that we wanted
to get and I said you know what
like just messing around when I was I
hadn't even been drafted I said put it
on me put that on my tab so he really
kept a running total that I never paid
it for like four years
and so finally he's like hey man
remember that thing that you said to put
on your tab or your half of a gym I said
yeah it's time to pay for that so I did
you know just being funny so yeah
absolutely
come on how much one did was it over ten
grand no no it was over it was
definitely over I won't get into the
details but I yeah it was definitely
over okay what are you driving I have a
truck of a Ford truck honk
yeah I have that I have a a little
two-door car that I like to drive around
Lodi and then uh and then my wife's got
her truck so yeah we like we like truck
selection up high on the road
so you haven't done a minivan thing in
no I try I tried though so David did you
know he has like 18 kids with like a dog
so he got a minivan and he put rims on
it he blacked out the windows
you know he put assistant you know he
put everything in this thing and his
wife comes rolling around and after
about I think three months he said yeah
I can't do this hello I'm Josh I think
I'm going to go for the passenger van
next I think that I'm going to do that
and try and sweep it up I like it where
you got the coin now that everybody
knows how much you make good luck going
on to the dealership a lot they're
they're going to be is coming daddy
record oh yeah hey congrats congrats on
the contract you're always one of our
favorites we appreciate you making time
for us and we'll talk to you when the
season starts I always think you doing I
appreciated month all right that's Derek
Carr he's very rich now the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience